what's going on guys this is Rob and
it's snowing here in Lexington the worst
snow that we've had in over ten years so
if you guys are like me and you're stuck
in their homes I figured I would do the
best I could to make this day a little
more bearable by answering the question
a lot of people have if Disney has
bought the Star Wars franchise then
where do we go from here
so following Disney purchasing the
rights of Star Wars the question a lot
of people had is where do you go from
here where do you start if you're
interested in reading the expanded
universe of Star Wars should you even
bother reading it in the first place so
what we're going to do is were going to
answer this question when the I guess
Return of the Jedi came out the
chronologically last of the Star Wars
films what we know is that this huge
expanded universe began to unfold even
more so than it had before and the
reason I say that is because after
episode I guess episode 4 after a new
hope which again was first the first
Star Wars film that had been released to
us it really caught people people love
the idea of Star Wars and so all these
different novels began to spout up we
saw novels based on the origins of Han
Solo we saw novels based on the life of
Princess Leia leading up to her
appearance in a Star Wars a new hope but
the problem here was that Disney was
faced with this almost insurmountable
situation because there were so many
expanded universe novels a majority of
which were basically based on the events
that took place after the The Return of
the Jedi and because they wanted to
bring back Star Wars films and to expand
on the universe through the films after
Return of the Jedi they had to make a
choice the choice being which one do
they choose do they make their films
based on the expanded universe or do
they create something separate and so
what they decided to do is create
something entirely different and so as a
result much to the chagrin of Star Wars
fans they basically wiped the entire
expanded universe and so what they said
is that anything that is not part of the
original six films that have been
released so far there is to say episodes
one two three four five and six or the
the Star Wars Clone Wars cartoon show
anything that's not part of that is not
considered official and this made comic
book fans and Marvel fans I'm sorry Tsar
Wars fans so angry then the reason why I
say comic fans is because for the
longest time Dark Horse Comics had been
publishing Star Wars comics they've been
basically giving us the comic book arm
of the Star Wars stories that took place
in the expanded universe some of which
were tie-ins to the film's different
things that had gone on and so when we
saw Disney finally took things over they
had taken the Star Wars franchise away
from Marvel ansan our way from Dark
Horse and they had given it to Marvel
Comics now this leads us and to Marvel
Comics launching
Star Wars issue number one now Star Wars
issue number one picks up immediately
after the events of Star Wars a new hope
and the reason why is because if you
guys recall with Star Wars a new hope
and the Empire Strikes Back all we had
known was that at the end of the at the
end of a new hope that Luke Skywalker
had blown up the Death Star and then we
immediately pick up with the Empire
Strikes Back and they're on Hoth the
question was how did we get to those two
places what transpired between Star Wars
a new hope and the Empire Strikes Back
that bridges the gap between those two
worlds this is what Star Wars issue
number one and the subsequent stories do
and so what we find is that the Empire
has basically reached out to Jabba the
Hutt with the intention of having Jabba
the Hutt become a weapons supplier for
the Empire but the goal here is to have
these weapons supplied out of one of the
biggest weapon Depot's that is known to
exist and so what's going to take place
is that the Empire is going to send a
negotiator of their own and if this
negotiator is going to meet with an
emissary of Jabba the Hutt and so what
we find is that when this emissary
arrives at the the weapons depot to meet
with the weapons depot overseer who of
course again works for the Empire we
find the word greeting where I guess
we're meeting with with Han Solo now
this is a passable thing as far as the
overseer is concerned and the reason why
is because the relationship between Han
Solo and Jabba the Hutt is well known
and so the Rebel Alliance is basically
using this as a way to effectively
convince everybody that their emissaries
now we also find that that Han Solo was
accompanied by a Princess Leia and Luke
Skywalker who are both disguised along
with r2d2 what we also find here is that
Chewbacca is overseeing this entire
thing not in the sense that a manager
capacity but in the sense that he's
basically their eyes in the sky he is
with the FM u f1 iam Falcon alongside
c-3po and that he's operating as a
sniper to ensure the protection in case
things were to pop off and so what
happens is that with the Han Solo and
Princess Leia and Luke Skywalker
continuing to pretend to be emissaries
that once they actually arrive to a
conference room where they're being held
they immediately tell this this overseer
to tell them where the I guess where the
Power Core is for this facility with her
intention of destroying it now the
overseer e doesn't initially want to
reveal this to him but once he I guess
once he's threatened by r2d2 with
electrocution the over
or tells the markets points them in the
direction of where it's ad but along the
way we also see that Luke Skywalker's
continuing to learn how to use his Jedi
powers he's continuing to learn how to
step into the role of being a Jedi
because again to keep in mind here Luke
Skywalker has not met Yoda and so the
only real training Luke Skywalker has is
a little experience he gained from
obi-wan Kenobi and whatever else that
happens to be that he learns along the
way and so one of the things that Luke
Skywalker stumbles across here is a
holding pin up in with various I guess
Empire slaves and so what he does is he
cuts off the arm of the guard after
failing to use a Jedi mind trick and
then frees the rest of the slaves but
what we also learn is that the
negotiator that's been sent by the
Empire is Darth Vader and so what's
going on here is that they're in a
situation whereby if Chewbacca were to
shoot Darth Vader then it would put the
entire base on alert which a han Solo
tells him not to do but because Princess
Leia is effectively the one running the
show here because she is as far as a
military standpoint the highest-ranking
person here as far as the Rebel Alliance
goes she tells to Baca to shoot Darth
Vader and when that happens the of
course the Darth Vader is able to
deflect the the blaster bolt and so as a
result the entire base is now put on
alert leading the the members of the
rebel group to scramble and to get out
of there as fast as they can but again
this really just sort of sets the stage
for things as we as we progress with
these Star Wars stories again this is
just issue number one and so what we'll
find is things progress with regards to
this whole Star Wars thing and so will
ultimately lead up to a set of
circumstances where we'll again continue
to see these holes filled in we'll
continue to see these things that built
on and to build up into something
spectacular with that being said we're
gonna go ahead and ring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace be sure to follow me on
Twitter there you can keep up with all
the updates from comics explained and
talk to me directly